100 i've been saying this for a long
time which is anybody who could figure
out how to employ the stay-at-home mom
workforce
is going to make billions of dollars
[Music]
dude this morning my friend had a 40th
birthday party and he rented out an
entire water park this morning from like
7 30 a.m to like 10 a.m
and i went to it yeah it was like me and
ramon and neville and then like you know
david perrell he was there and a bunch
of other guys are there and i it was so
fun we had this whole park to ourselves
and then i came home and like threw up
and went to sleep
like
you caught something because you you
threw about a nostalgia why are you
puking i didn't like when i was a kid i
used to love that stuff and then i did
all these like slides and like went too
hard and like going through them like
like you go like these slides are it's
kind of hard to explain but you're like
in that you know those tubes that like
go in twisties
like it just made me sick to my stomach
i i was like on the right home i was
like no i think i might throw up can you
uh unlock the window
i couldn't believe how like old i got
you savage you threw up out the window
you didn't no i didn't do it out the
window but i came home and i got sick
and i just had to lay down i cannot
believe how
life has changed
like you didn't even drink it just just
the straight just the action
just like the like well did you go to
rides at disney
uh like that my daughter's two so i did
only like the dumbo ride like the most
simple rides i don't like i think it was
a little crazy i think i would have done
like the big stuff i think i would throw
up at this point i couldn't handle it it
was horrible um but man this is why
austin is awesome so like
okay so david perrl i don't know him
that well but
uh just two blocks up there's this
restaurant and me and sarah went out to
breakfast and he was there and so i he
we knew who each others were and we just
said what's good but now we're gonna go
hang out last night i had this guy over
named chris williamson do you know who
that is
no he's like a popular youtuber and he
just dm'd me he said i'm in austin do i
hang out i go yeah just come over for
dinner uh
like we're just constantly just seeing
people it's pretty wild it's a small
weird it's like a a lot of like cool
people here but it's a small town
yeah that used to be the case in san
francisco you know because
you would just bump into people
everywhere
that were like doing the same thing
like-minded people who are also in the
same game
but um
i don't know i moved out of the city now
so like you know i'm in the burb my
neighbor is 80 years old uh you know if
i bump into him you know he's telling me
about like you know crochet or something
like that so it's not the same
well it's it's awesome here i've
thoroughly enjoyed it um
you want to get into some stuff yeah you
have a bunch of really interesting
things to talk about i've got less
interesting things to talk about
yeah let's do it let's pick one um
actually let me let me let me lead with
mine because i have less stuff this is
pretty much the only thing but you talk
to this person all right this woman
named rebecca zamalo you talked to her
right
yeah i think you butchered her last name
zamarollo zamarello sorry
all right so i did a call with her as
well i i dm'd her and and we and we
started talking
this woman is amazing so basically it's
her and her husband her husband's name's
matt they're partners on this she has a
youtube channel it's
anyone listening to this you only
probably know about it if you have kids
so it's meant for children it's like
it's like acting like fictional stuff
age uh like six to eight uh six to ten
ish maybe where it's like it's not the
like absolute beginner kitty coco melon
type of stuff it's like somewhere
between and yeah they basically like
it's a little show it's a t it's almost
like a tv show uh you know whether it's
blues clues or whatever else there they
create like you know these videos these
little 10-minute videos that are
entertaining and on her personal channel
she's got like 10 or 12 million
subscribers she has seven other seven
channels total so six other channels one
for her dog one for her husband one for
like this
for gaming just like all types of stuff
she's releasing eight videos a week they
have a team of like eight or six people
maybe and she kind of told me a little
bit about some of like the business
numbers
my mind was blown it was astounding
unbelievable it was unbelievable did you
talk to her about her business we can't
like i didn't ask her if i could say
anything and she wouldn't like that but
i put that on blast but yeah i i like
the you know the dog has ten times maybe
20 times more subscribers than we do on
youtube like it's like oh this is my
dog's gaming channel and it'll have like
400 000 subscribers or something crazy
so she gets youtube
has i mean 10 million subscribers is no
joke
and the amount of production the content
output like just that thing you said it
sounded like oh six like seven eight
videos a week it's like okay so they do
a video they release video pretty much
every day but they're like 40 minute
long sometimes yeah they're like long
videos with like story lines about like
and she'll be like you know um
yeah we moved into this new house and
there was like this weird door in my
bedroom so we created this storyline
about this like secret secret passage
that takes you down and then there's a
villain inside and the villain is my
husband and like that's the like they
create a whole play basically a little
screenplay and they shoot it and while
we were talking she's like yeah
downstairs there's like eight people for
our crew like our kind of film audio uh
you know editors whatever that are all
here and she's like yeah my life is
crazy it's it's it was wild and she was
telling me about different stuff and so
there's this guy named dar darmon so his
first name is dar d h i know him well
yeah okay so
you're friends with them i'm not friends
with them uh my wife
either knew him like in college or
something like that or whatever but then
we've uh done some deals with that him
and his wife around like influencer
content so he's got 13.8 million
subscribers and it's
it's kind of lame what he does like lame
in that it's not going to fit what we we
do but basically it's like hallmark
channel videos like one was like bully
someone bullies an autistic kid and the
reaction is crazy or and it's like a
fictional hallmark video i think they
like children watch it i guess to
understand like values
and he's got something like a hundred
employees and he's brand new to this
like
within a three-year thing yeah like two
three years a hundred employees and they
pump these videos out to the point of
like right now he's got 6.3 billion
views
and it is crazy and across all their
platforms their videos have been viewed
27 billion times uh it's the some of
these youtubers it is i'm just blown
away at how big their businesses are and
when i'm thinking about it
and i talked to rebecca i'm like this
actually isn't that hard i could do this
and if you dedicate like 40 or 50 hours
a week if you start from scratch you can
get big really fast and but you have to
treat it like a job not a hobby just
like anything else
yeah like a business not even a job
because yeah business managing a bunch
of people and you gotta have a product
for customers and things like that so so
yeah i totally agree um like i'm on his
uh twitter so
it says like new videos monday through
thursday family friendly kid approved
right this is a that is a product you're
offering we yeah we release on these
days we are kid-friendly rated g
uh you know like here's what you're
gonna get out of this and that's that's
you know my studio company or whatever
um and i think but by the way before
this this guy i think he was doing like
a cannabis company an e-commerce thing
yeah they have an e-commerce and
cannabis
business like unrelated he's doing all
kinds of stuff
it's it's amazing it's incredible um
these youtubers like i'm blown away
because there's so many that you have no
idea who they are but they have these
empires that could be potentially making
tens of millions of dollars a year
yeah i i also think um
you know it's really hard to do what
they're doing um like you know the
it's not for everybody uh and i i guess
that's kind of obvious but
uh i guess what i'm trying to say is
even if you could do it not everybody
could do it but even if you could do it
doesn't mean you should do it like this
is such a hard thing to do to get on
that treadmill and say i'm gonna produce
awesome content five days a week
non-stop and if i ever stop the
algorithm punishes me and my subscribers
leave my channel and my patreon people
stop giving me money and my i don't have
ad content for my sponsors and if i ever
you know just don't feel like being in
front of the camera like it doesn't work
there's no substitute teacher to um
to you know step in here and and step
into this business so i think it is a
really valuable
i think it's a powerful business when
you have it because anytime you have the
trust of millions of people who like
your entertainment that's great
but man um
i don't think it's worth it uh you know
just i i'm not even just saying that
theoretically like i've thought about
doing it and i'm like there's no way
this is worth it for me
yeah i i and that's what i said to her
and so this guy dar i think he's not
like the face i believe in most of his
videos i don't think i think he's
enclosed in none of his videos or
something like that with her she was
like yeah but we've got all these seven
other channels now so we diversified
beyond just me and i agree with you i
think that that's a hard treadmill but i
would say to the the other side is like
everything is that right if you start
anything like you of course you just
gotta work at it for a long time
um i think i could share this but when i
did the episode when i recorded with
husband minaj who's like you know
comedian uh he's on tv shows stuff like
that he um he had asked me at one point
during the thing i think the episode's
coming out soon um
the he had asked me like you know uh
like what would you do next step if you
were me
he asked you that
yeah like kind of like okay from a
business point of view what would you do
next
and um
on the pod itself i don't think i got
him i gave him a great answer like
i think in the pod we were talking more
about like how would you invest your
money
and um i was like you know
here's kind of the thought process i
would go down it was kind of a boring
lame answer i would to be honest but
afterwards when we were hanging out
i i told him what i think is actually
the real answer for this i said you know
everybody should do what fits them like
something that looks exhausting to me
might look might feel amazing to
somebody else so you know don't take my
word for it but let's just pretend i'm
just going to give you my two cents and
you could throw it away if you don't
like it um i said if i was you
this touring business model seems
awesome because i was at your show it
was so you know like 4 000 seats sold
out everyone you know every average
ticket's like 150 bucks and you just did
that eight times in this city and then
you're gonna go to 50 cities on this
tour like you could just add it up and
be like wow
you can make a lot of money touring and
um and then there's no limit to that
like yeah this is a 4 000 person
auditorium but you could do your same
set in front of 30 000 people in a
bigger stadium if like you know chris
rock or dane cook or whoever these other
people would do that that size tours so
i said you got a business model that
works
and but the problem is you're i was like
you're a new dad like me like i can't
imagine being on the road going to 50
cities like we've been invited to many
things i've been like yeah and then i'm
like uh traveling is so hard a little
kid i got to leave my wife i don't
really want to leave the house for an
extended period of time right now like i
like being home
so i was like you don't for me i would
want to get rid of the travel component
i said okay how do you do that you can't
have a substitute teacher come in and
say your jokes on stage that doesn't
work and so what i had told him
afterwards i go if i was you
i would stash cash and i would create a
two-year runway
where i could just work on one thing and
that is creating
the next hamilton
and he's like what and i was like i
would use your storytelling your comedic
abilities
i would create hamilton for brown people
because that's like his audience is his
demographic is like heavily skewed asian
and i said um i'll create hamilton for
brown people i don't know what that
means i would just take that and say i'm
doing that and then he's like you know
he reacted to it or whatever and i was
like the reason i would do that is
because then you get the business model
of touring but it's not you on the stage
you all you only have to create it once
and like mamma mia has been running for
[__] 16 years and has done over 600
million dollars in ticket sales and um
you know like hamilton's done over a
billion dollars in ticket sales and it's
the same story it's the same songs it's
the same jokes every night done by a
different cast of kind of
like
you know fungible or interchangeable
pieces so you're not super dependent on
any one talent like you can switch it
off switch switch out people if you need
so i was like that to me seems like an
amazing business model i would do that
so that that's kind of my example of
this youtube thing is like
you can also do the youtube thing but in
a different way like i think it's cool
that dar isn't the face of his videos so
then it's more like a production company
it's like a tv show he's created not so
much a vlog dude there's this guy uh
people are gonna laugh at me because i
don't know or if you know who this is uh
is it andrew lloyd webber i forget who i
forget the guy's name is that the fan of
the opera guy yeah and did he do joseph
uh
something jesus radical what's that that
broadway show where it's like radical
jesus or like jesus's uh
it's like about jesus and then there's
like this christ
yes [__] it
yes
school of rock phantom of the opera and
evita which are all big hits that i've
heard of and then i've never heard of
jesus christ superstar but yeah that's
apparently like done in the 70s yeah he
uh he's a billionaire
yeah so so i looked up so when i thought
of that play model i was like is the
play is the play business a good
business it could be and i think it can
be so the the top
the top ip
definitely accrues like a [__] ton of
value like i said if you you can go look
at like lion king is grossed like two
point something billion dollars uh
that's the number one stage play
two and three hamilton is like getting
up there it's like it's like number two
or three now but it's like very new so
it'll it'll surpass lion king if it just
keeps going um there's like fan of the
opera there's mamma mia there's like so
you take the top ten and they're all
doing like hundreds of millions in gross
sales okay now you don't get to keep the
gross sales but i think you
could do this in a way that works so
like the guy who created hamilton lynn
manuel whatever his name is yeah but did
the uh did the author get paid too on
that one
uh so he gets so this guy lynn who's the
creator of it he uh has like a seven
percent royalty or something like that
wow so he's made like tens of millions
of dollars off of the the profits they
actually crowdfunded the thing so what
they did i don't have the full story in
front of me because i'm just trying to
say this off top my head from a memory
but
i think what they did was to raise the
money to create the thing they had like
a bunch of patrons basically chipping
money and they all get to keep a profit
share after a certain amount of money
had been recouped and so that investment
has been paid over like 10 times so if
again if i was hustling i'd be like hmm
there's web3 [__] going on interesting a
lot of people flush with cash buying
into [__] okay cool digital tickets nfts
okay what can i do with this and i would
basically
raise 10 million dollars
through an nft pre-sale
of the show
and uh in different tiers like you know
some of the tickets have backstage
passes attached to them some of them
don't whatever that's interesting and
and i would i would just let people buy
buying this i'd raise 10 million dollars
i'd use the 10 million dollars to go
into a bunker to create whatever the
health hamilton black people is
and then i would hamilton brown people
for indians
oh yeah sorry not black people brown
people so then i would take that show on
the road and i would just try to i would
be like yeah i know it's hard but like
being a successful stand-up comedian was
also like a 0.1 success rate or whatever
um you know to get to where he's at so
like yeah you want to get to the point
one percent success rate but this time
with a superior business model that um
doesn't require your face on the stage
saying the jokes
yeah i think that's sick i think that's
a that's a great idea i think that's
actually that's wonderful i think and
that could be incredibly creative
creatively fulfilling
i wish i had said it on the spot it's
like one of those when you're in an
argument and then like later you're
interested i said that oh [__] i should
have said that that's what happened to
me but luckily we were still hanging out
at that moment so i was able to tell him
you know then ah this is a cool idea i
think in the next couple episodes what
i'm going to do is i'm actually going to
bring in uh i'm going to do some
research on the broadway business or
like i don't know theater i guess what
do you call it theater yeah um it's
actually an interesting idea i was
always curious because american idiot
basically they did this so billy joe
armstrong
wrote green day wrote american idiot the
album the song they turned it into a uh
a rock musical right you didn't have to
be there they didn't have to be there
you know exactly and
they got paid a lot from it book of
mormon let me see how much book of
mormon has made
of mormon
yeah
500 million dollars has been the gross
ticket sales of book of mormon and then
if you did something like a hamilton or
like a lion king or whatever you could
take that same ip those characters you
have merch you have like other
that ips you okay is you got to own the
ip
and um
you know so so i think you know when
that when book of mormon launched it
says it was bringing bringing in 19
million per month so like i don't know
what south park generated lifetime but
like i bet it's kind of like on par with
that uh or you know i guess south park's
probably a bigger success
um
yeah
oh wow south park
okay just in 20 i didn't know this
happened actually it looks like a couple
months ago the south park creator signed
a 900 million deal for more episodes for
for uh six years uh with viacom cbs
that's insane i didn't know that that's
actually amazing that's amazing right
now is the best time ever to be a like a
production company or an ip holder and
we said this a long time ago remember i
said someone needs to there's all these
platforms now you got
at the time it was netflix amazon prime
and then i said disney plus was going to
come out it hadn't come out yet
and then there was like you know there's
hulu there's all these different
platforms apple tv plus came out
they all want original content they're
all hungry for content and they are
betting billions of dollars
budgeting every single year to buy
content i think netflix or amazon or
something like they're paying like six
billion dollars per year for content uh
for new content production and so it is
the best time ever to be a seller of
content and at the time we had said
somebody should create yc for content
basically the way that y combinator
helped produce software startups and it
just said hey two engineers okay you're
21 years old you grad it from stanford
all right come here this is essentially
like a business school but you're going
to create a little business and you know
maybe you can sell to facebook or google
or you'll end up becoming the next
airbnb you'll go public
i think the same thing with the content
where you come in as two kind of like
creatives you have a pitch for an idea
of a show you want to create um
you have three months to basically
create the sizzle reel or the pilot or
whatever and then there's a demo day
with a bunch of buyers from all the big
streaming platforms and they just buy
options on your [__] and um i just think
that's a beautiful i still think that's
a great business idea and it's only been
proven when
south park signs a 900 million deal with
with cbs uh shonda rhimes i think signed
a couple hundred million dollar deal
with netflix to produce six shows um
reese witherspoon sold her production
company which didn't even have that like
for like a billion for like a billion
dollars
like this is you know this is tech
startup money that's being sold for for
tv content which is amazing so you know
that's a that's way more fun than
building software
way more way cooler um way cooler than
that and i think today house minaj also
announced his production he created a
production company today he announced it
like 100 i think it's called 186k
productions or something like that which
is smart again like once you see reese
witherspoon and other people's
production companies selling and we had
rob deer deck on i think he said he sold
his production company for 200 something
million he said that he i think he said
he's walking away with 100 him
personally
yeah so like i think you know at least
let's say at least 100 million probably
closer to 200 million he sold his
production company which basically just
produced shows for mtv
that's a great business to be in and i
think it's only going to get better for
like this kind of five year period and
then these platforms are going to go
away like paramount plus
and you know like quibby died you know
paramount plus what the [__] is that
that's good i love paramount plus
why do you love fairmont what's the one
show you love on there there's gotta be
one
they have uh like a lot of documentaries
and [__] paramount it's like old older
it's like old school a little bit or
like peacock are you subscribed to
peacock hell yeah
i literally was just when i was laying
in bed when i wasn't feeling good i
watched the office on peacock peacock is
the only place that you can get the
office the nbc's one right yeah you
could
the office in parks and rec it's the
only place you can get it and then so i
use it for parks and rec the office and
ap bio or have you seen ap bio no i
don't know what that is it's like with
the class i took in high school it's
like the main guy from it's always sunny
you know uh dee's brother dennis yeah
yeah it's sick uh but peacock's good man
pika it's just it all costs so much
money at all i was looking to [__] on
one of them i thought peacock was safe
but uh i guess no peacock's cool you're
sponsored by peacock i guess i don't
know what's going on i pay i pay for
this man a
dude do you have so much stuff here
let's just
bang through it yeah let's do one uh
okay so let's do um
do this tweet thing
okay let's do this tweet so this guy sue
hale who created mixpanel and now is
creating mighty which is a cool company
have we talked about mighty by the way
yeah
it's pretty awesome i think we talked
about it so yeah we'll skip that for now
anyways good entrepreneur
cool guy whatever he tweeted this thing
out
and uh my tweet's not loading right now
but i think it was something along the
lines of it it said
what's a company you'd start if you had
more energy time or a lot more money
right so which is basically like if you
took away your [__] ass reasons
what's the thing you really should be
working on right now i find that to be a
very interesting question i have another
question that's similar to that so maybe
we'll do both of these questions today
so i went through the replies and i want
to read you
five of my favorite replies and i want
you to just give me a gut reaction
hell yeah hell no or i don't [__] get
it um
okay so the first one came from gary tan
who's a
you know big shot investor guy
um first investor in coinbase made like
a billion dollars on that so he he said
a reference check network do you know
what that means just when i say just
that yeah yeah so uh well the problem
being solved is how to get uh like if
he's gonna want to invest in someone hey
does anyone know is this person uh
honest
right or you're hiring somebody and you
wanna know okay yeah you worked at this
place how do i get a reference check so
normally today you ask the employee they
give you three names of course those are
the three people that are only gonna say
good things which is kind of annoying in
the first place so you can't get really
get the right people then you kind of
have to bug them there's no real
incentive for them except for to maybe
help out their their ex employee and
then you have to think of whatever
questions you're going to ask most
people ask pretty poor questions but
there are better ways of doing it and in
the end you're just trying to get this
fuzzy picture of like you know is this
person any good or not so that can be
done better and i think he had some
solution in mind which is like
something on the blockchain which was
just like
um
you are able to like i'm able to have
people who are linked to me somebody can
go and request a reference from them
maybe there's a little payment made i'm
not sure and then they share information
but it's not publicly shared it's just
shared privately with me given the
context of
you know who's who's the employee and
what what this job is so i thought that
was all right
um i thought it was really specific one
that i thought was cool cause there was
a lot of like
i'd solve clean energy and like i don't
really know what to do
like it's not that that's a bad mission
it's just like what the [__] am i
supposed to say about that okay somebody
else said create the largest employer of
high school students in the u.s what do
you think of that
sick
sick yeah i mean that's a
that sounds awesome yes i mean what is
that now mcdonald's
yeah like i mean
i mean probably honestly i guess
it might be like mcdonald's i don't know
what that would be i talked to these
guys who were building a company i
forget what it was called you probably
know what it was but it's basically like
an id indeed.com but it's meant for
teens and it looks like tick-tock and
like panda express and uh mcdonald's and
like pacsun were all advertising on it
and you could like scroll through and
look at job opportunities yeah i want to
say it was called like peach something
or like lemon something or something
like that i don't remember i don't
remember but uh panda express was like
spending a ton of money on it um and so
uh anyway yeah i think that's cool i
think it's a great idea uh it's not a
good idea it's a great prize to go for i
actually would say that this is like an
interesting framework which is who do
you want to employ
100 i've been saying this for a long
time which is anybody who could figure
out how to employ the stay-at-home mom
workforce
is going to make billions of dollars so
if you just work backwards from there's
a bunch of moms at home
they want to earn a little extra income
doesn't have to be a ton
they want to maintain flexibility of
being able to stay at home and work not
like necessarily a fixed number of
full-time hours or the same hours every
day who can solve that problem and um
there's only one example that i know of
that's solving that problem i don't know
if you know any
um for moms yeah
uh maybe uservoice.com i think they do
it uh testing usertesting.com that's the
one i was thinking about oh is it really
my mom my mom worked for them yeah so oh
my god that's so funny i knew about it
what a random thing that we both knew
that um
so i would say so use testing.coming by
the way so you just pay someone to like
go through your website public by the
way um and how cool is this they just
went public and my mom stuck and my mom
was like
well say what it is
so user testing basically it's a service
where i have an app or a website i want
to know
where it's confusing for users like
design makes sense to me but like sure
enough when somebody else is using it
they're confused they can't find the
thing they want and they just record
your mom like scrolling through the site
so they have an army of testers which is
just all the requirement is be a normal
person you have we do not even want you
to be highly skilled like you're
supposed to represent the average
customer so they have a bunch of people
they send them a little camera that um
that records their finger on their phone
basically it records them like and they
just talk out loud so that you give a
task you say like you know find a
christmas gift for your dad and put it
into your cart and they're like okay i'm
looking for the gifts for dad section i
don't see it uh scrolling scrolling
scrolling they don't see the button that
says menu oh there's the menu uh
dad oh it's men's men's okay i'll click
men's um
yeah i don't get how this is sorted oh
this is by new release and you just talk
through what's confusing to you and that
15-minute video goes to the company and
the company gets to watch it and they
get to share it internally their their
researcher basically shares it with the
designer or the engineer they pay like
300 for it right
no no each test is like 25 or 30 dollars
and then um
and then well now it's all switched to
subscription but originally it was like
25 30 a test the tester gets 10 bucks
for doing the test and the company kept
you know 15 20 bucks and so the tester's
like cool i could do like four of these
in an hour and so a like a bid would
come online oh chipotle wants you to
test their new mobile menu and you would
just have to go quickly say yes and then
you qualify they're looking for women
you know age 40 to 55 in the u.s and
you're like yeah great i qualify i can
take this test that's a billion dollar
company now it's market cap is over a
billion dollars did your mom get paid
did they give her shares yeah it's
awesome so basically my mom was she
first started off as a tester then she
got hired by the company to review the
other testers because you have to do
quality control so she became like she
would watch the test and give feedback
to the testers like hey your audio sucks
or like you're mumbling or like
you didn't follow the instructions of
the test um one more strike and you're
out of the testing pool and so that was
her job and she was the oldest person in
the company i think so she was like my
mom's like 63 now so she just retired
this year so she was there at 62 years
old my mom like had slack and like knew
how to use all like jira she knew what a
jira ticket was like it was crazy my mom
like who knew
and
she got some shares and she had always
told me like should i i was like yeah
you want the shares for sure um and then
she would tell me like
hey the ceo did an all hands he said
this this this is that good i'm like
yeah it sounds good like this company's
doing well i should have bought
secondary stock in the company during
that time because i had like basically
inside info of like this company's
pretty good is a good quality company
and i was a user of the service as well
so it goes public the other day like
like two weeks ago
and i'm like mom how many shares do you
have and she goes looks in carter she
tells me to share i'm like mom you made
150 000
no way and she's like yeah because her
strike price was super low uh she was
there for like four or five years and uh
so i was like that's amazing that's like
uh like that's that my mom was so happy
yeah like
for her that's badass
and so like this is why i think this
model of who do you want to pull is
actually interesting because
it's actually
there it's two for two reasons it's
motivating so like the fact that like
they are employing uh mostly like i have
no idea i should make this up if it's
like mostly women who stayed at home for
a long time and now they want to get
back to it that's like incredibly
motivating it's like look we're serving
our employees yeah it's very noble it's
cool let's say you want to hire uh uh
ex-cons or something it's like look this
is interesting or we're gonna hire a
bunch of 16 year olds and it's gonna be
the first job we're gonna train them how
to be uh men and women and prepare them
for the rest of their lives it's
actually incredibly cool it's
fascinating there's one um i wanna look
up the name give him a shout out here so
it's higher you hire a military
wives as eas that's awesome it's called
and it also helps with expectations so
you know what you're wearing
you what's it called squared away
squared away that's cool a woman i think
i think her story is that she
i'm assuming
she was in this position i don't really
know
but basically it's military spouses um
and i was like this is a great
this is a great idea um because you know
this is u.s
these are u.s employees they want this
work they um you know they it's great to
provide for their family while you know
the husband's away i just think it's
awesome and um
and it's it helps significantly with
expectations because then user testing
knows all right we're
hiring a ton of 17 year old high school
kids like we know like here's the
deficiencies and here's where they kick
ass or we're hiring guys out of jail we
know like here's where they're going to
struggle here's we're not going to show
so that's cool um what are what are some
other
great ones on here that's a good one
it's kind of vague but pretty cool i'll
do two more um
okay
we'll do one vr therapy
so um vr is not there for like
mainstream use cases the average
person's not coming home and spending a
couple hours of vr there's a few there
are some people who do it they like to
play games uh but vr is really awesome
for like
for like training like i know
doctor like medical schools buy it so
that the doctor can be like in the
operating room they can make a highly
lifelike simulation um
and i think therapy is a good one too so
um being able to put a headset on and
really like change your environment
change the state of mind be able to go
role play through scenarios or talk to
somebody and feel like you're there with
them i think that's kind of amazing and
so i look forward to seeing like vr with
these like really specific high-value
use cases
um until like the mainstream thing is
ready dude i'm down with that i also
think i could conquer a bunch of phobias
like with that right so i'm down i think
that's cool like i know that like
athletes are doing this so like you know
um there's this great we both love uh
like you know ufc and mma and
nfl is this way also but there there's
this phrase that conor mcgregor's coach
always says which is you want to upgrade
the software without damaging the
hardware so it's like how do you train
and improve
without the without putting strain on
the body hurting your body because
training is so physically grueling
so one way that they're doing it in the
nfl is vr headsets the quarterback
instead of just watching film
their first person
reading the defense without having to go
stretch get their ankles taped up go out
on the field potentially you know sprain
a knee or get hit it's like they get to
ex they get to re practice reading the
defense and all the different coverages
just in vr and then when they get out
there on the field like it's that same
first person point of view being able to
turn your head and you're you're only
seeing parts of the field like it's like
pretty much like a one-to-one recreation
i think that's kind of awesome i want to
know which company's doing that um
i'm sure there's a company doing that my
favorite videos on youtube to watch
right now are they take
folks who play uh
simul racing sims so racing simulations
with vr sets and they have these like
amazing setups at home that are like ten
twenty fifty thousand dollars and then
they go and put them in a race car
and uh they do really
good no they do really well you know it
takes them like in all the videos i've
seen it takes him five ten twenty
minutes to like get used to the noise
and get used to um
like the smell and just the the slightly
different sensation but they pick it up
super fast and so it's guys who have
actually never raced before and they get
them out there and they give them the
fast cars and they pick that [__] up
it's pretty amazing
yeah like i think even stuff as boring
as sales i think you could practice
sales in a much more lifelike way
i know that teachers are doing this for
like
how to talk to your student about if
they're feeling depressed or if they're
being bullied it's like you sit there a
student walks in you can see their face
they're saying something and then you
have to react and then you have to like
you're kind of like choosing what to say
live it's it makes it you get to
practice before you go do the real thing
that's cool any other good ones
uh there was a couple other ambitious
ones so there's a terraformation one
we've talked about this before which is
taking
just
deserts on the on earth and turning them
into like rain forests basically turning
them into forests like putting creating
a green oasis of trees there and like
that cleans up that sucks up a bunch of
carbon dioxide from the environment so
it cleans up uh you know the the air as
well as like turns it into livable land
and so like if we can learn how to
terraform which is basically like
turned you know unlivable land into
livable land um that's gonna help earth
but it'll also help when we finally do
make it to mars and we need to turn that
into a hospitable place we're gonna need
to know how to do terra formation so i
thought that was kind of interesting and
there's another one like that like drone
based wildfire fighting so like sending
in drones to put out wildfires i think
that's pretty cool too i think that's
great those are really neat what um
what's what's another one what's this
legal question for five million dollars
this i thought was cool all right so
there's so as you know i'm a tick-tock
binger nowadays and tick-tock is the
only social media that like i
when i leave it i feel better than when
i came in
everything else like facebook feel awful
at the end instagram i feel like oh man
my brain is rotting twitter i'm like i
was a waste of time just dealing with a
bunch of people's bad thoughts and uh
tic tac is really i i cannot believe how
much i enjoy it like is it just
entertaining addictive it's
entertainment but there's a lot of
education like i learned a lot of [__]
off dick talk now it's all little life
stuff it's like
um
like i don't know those stupid examples
but like hey if you ever take a photo
and you see that like you know where
you're like when you take a photo your
eye can have like a red like you know
you look kind of evil like the camera
has that flash or whatever like a red
dot if that's ever white you should go
to the doctor um because there's
actually like a very uh like there's a
chance that that's a very bad thing and
then this guy was replying saying
actually i had heard that i saw him a
photo like the land of that i went to
the doctor i trust i had eye cancer he's
like i actually have my eye removed but
like it saved my life that we found it
early and um i don't know this is random
[__] that to like you know
just quickly seeing like how an avocado
gets to your door it's like oh cool this
farmer farmer tick tock is dope like
parenting tick tock is great it's like
oh when your kid is just not listening
how many times have you done this i'm
like yeah [__] that's me and they're
like here's a better way to say it i'm
like thanks you know parent i never had
to teach me how to do this really
important thing in my life um like you
just learn little [__]
so um
anyways i was on it and there's this
account called legal baddie uh legal
batty is just like some hot lawyer and
she's like here's my question for you
she goes
if i told you that you were gonna make
five million dollars a year as your
salary regardless of what you do so
you're just you're going to work 30 40
hours a week you're gonna make a fixed
rate of five million dollars a year what
would you choose to do as your work
like you still have to work to get it uh
what would you choose as your job
and obviously this is like you know a
hidden question of kind of like what do
you actually really enjoy to do if money
wasn't an issue
um
and so and but you still have to work
right so there's one of like oh if i had
100 million dollars well then i probably
maybe it wouldn't work at all like maybe
i would just do blah blah blah this is
like you have to work to earn this
but no matter what job you do you're
going to earn the same amount so which
job by the way i'm looking at her
profile i love legal batty i love this
woman
why
it's just her look what do you like
she's just like she's a daddy she's
she's this one's a lawyer is that her
her shtick
yeah she's i think she's a lawyer
otherwise i just think it's maybe trust
and eagle mean something else i don't
know what's going on if this woman she's
19 and that's where she's going first
gen lawyer from ucla law
i think it's amazing she's probably
making more money off tick tock
and like she's like i like i like i
particularly like it with women but i
like it with men too where they uh talk
about like cool [__] like passing the
bar exam or whatever but then like uh
like she's got a bunch of nail [__] i i
always think it's cool where like you
can break that barrier of like smut
and cool stuff and also like legitimate
uh life helping content i always thought
that was cool yeah exactly yeah i'm with
you she has 500 000 followers on uh on
here and like you know her top videos
yeah she's like doing like like
purposely hot girl stuff and then also
like telling you how to get into law
school i always i always think that's
cool law school and then downer dog then
back to quick bar exam tip and then back
to my favorite name and like here's like
a here's like a a pretty racy bikini
video of her
right
so yeah she knows what she's doing right
like let's
credit where credit is due
uh she is giving the market what it
wants i love this differentiated thing
all right she's not just one of the like
kind of like tick-tock hot girl in a
bikini or whatever like she layered it
with
another like that this the skill stack
as you call it right how rare is that
there's there's not a lot of lawyers on
tick tock there's not a lot of hot girls
both she might be the only one right so
she's competing in a pool of one and
there's this video of her talking in
front of like c-span like
some type of
press con i love this anyway i love her
uh so what's the question five million
dollars what would your job be
yeah what would you do for your job if
you were for sure gonna get paid 5
million what would you just choose to do
for that 30 40 hours a week what's your
answer now i want to hear yours first i
don't know it comes to mind
five million dollars a year and you have
to have like a 40 hour a week job right
yeah
um
definitely something involving like
charity so like uh something involving
not making money so if i can get five
million dollars and all i have to do is
like spend time like running a dog
shelter or uh
uh that's awesome i would do that in a
heartbeat if i could pay five minutes
that's not what i thought you were gonna
say if i could do five million dollars
to like run like a dog rescue i would do
that in a heartbeat or to help inmates
ex-inmates find jobs i think that would
be exciting so or even like people like
everything we just discussed about
helping uh stay-at-home moms get on get
employment anything that involves
helping people and not making money i
would do that
yeah that's good uh yeah mine's kind of
similar mine's kind of boring i would
probably teach like i just love teaching
so
um i would teach now the question is
what would i teach i think i would teach
kind of like business slash life stuff
to people who
uh
want to actually like they're really
motivated to have a great life and have
a great great like kind of business
career and so those are the people i
like hanging out with the most
and that's the thing i like doing the
most is basically learning [__] and then
just
you know packaging it up and then
teaching each other and answering
questions you know talking things
through basically with people figuring
stuff out um so i think that's probably
what i would do but i feel like you know
your dog shelter thing made me think oh
maybe there's an even more lightweight
um just pure enjoyment like maybe
actually i know what it would probably
be i would be like a um
i'd be a basketball coach or i would be
like a uh
like whatever the f minus basketball
league is like i'd be a basketball
player because like that'd be something
that's the travel absolute most fun
doing is playing basketball and like
second best would be coaching a
basketball team this woman legal batty
has another question would you rather
have 10 million dollars today or 100
million in five years
that's the easiest question ever
which one would you take 105 yeah
exactly 105 is is is great um
it gets if it's 50 i think it's a lot
closer it gets a lot closer at 50
because 50 could turn into a hundred in
five years in a bulk market
10 10 will turn into 20 but also you got
to have 10 now and you don't have to
wait five years of your life which is
you know pretty significant uh but yeah
i think my answer is i'd be on some
gordon bombay [__] and i'd go do my
mighty ducks thing with some like you
know high school team i think that's a
good answer um
you wanna do a few more let's do
something else let's do it let's do a
couple ideas so business idea all right
problem i just ran into
um sending a gift to
your production partner your factory
partner uh overseas okay sending gifts
in general is hard sending gifts
overseas even harder um because like
just like the act of mailing things like
oh i want to send them like you know a
bottle of wine for christmas or whether
it's like i can't mail that how do i do
this i gotta go look up ups like alcohol
shipment you know rules and make sure it
doesn't crack and all this
so i i was searching like i'd like to
send my factory a gift in china is there
just like a version of doordash in china
i could just like
go look at what they have push a button
and they'll just deliver it to them and
like
it's done
and i actually found this like really
janky website um
i'm gonna find uh i'm gonna
find the name of it um but basically i
found this like old school looking
craigslist looking website and it was we
send gifts to your business partners in
east asia and it's like that's all we do
um brows here's like 50 gift baskets
ranging from like balling out to like ah
we just met and um you know you want to
spend 40 do you want to spend
400 you could you could pick and they
just say great what and then their
address field is like formatted for
chinese address it's like you know like
it's like it's just it's optimized where
you have confidence that they will
actually deliver the goods and i'm not
gonna have to worry about logistics i'm
just gonna be able to put in some money
and i'm gonna have a thoughtful gift to
my factory partner so i like this idea
because okay there's probably some
amount of people like me that are
searching for this like okay it's
christmas i want to get a gift for my
business partner but do they not have
can you not order an amazon thing and
send it to china
no i don't think so oh i don't i don't
know maybe yeah maybe i could have just
done something as simple as that i don't
think i don't think so but maybe there's
like maybe i needed to go on taobao and
like figure that out yeah but that's the
pain yes because i don't even know what
it is exactly this was like pay with
paypal you're done and i was like great
um this is what i wanted and it was also
like organized as a gift so it wasn't
just like an item where they're just
gonna get in a shitty amazon box it's
like it looks like a gift it's a gift
cat care package um which is nice that's
like the goal of what i was trying to do
it's like edible arrangements to china
is what i was trying to do essentially
so i sent it and um
and i was just thinking you could just
do this and then do like cold outreach
to like the one million shopify stores
and be like hey
you know it's a good idea you should
send your your factory you know your
your manufacturer basket a gift basket
and like you know a costume box it goes
a long way you know these people you
know they're they're key to your
business and study shell blah blah and
gifting is a big thing in china it shows
respect don't be rude um and like you
could do that three times a year like oh
it's you know chinese new year it's
whatever else and i think just through
outbound you could create like a
probably like a one million dollar a
year uh revenue business maybe three
million dollars a year
in like two weeks i think you could
create that so our uh listen to this
crap so so the other day we got a
mattress delivered to our front door a
zionist mattress it's huge and it had
sarah's name on it i go sarah why'd you
order a mattress because i didn't order
a mattress
and i'm like we gotta find out who sent
this mattress because we can't open this
up because if you open it up it's a pain
in the butt we're just gonna keep in the
box maybe send it back or we'll sell it
for like 200 or give it to a friend yeah
so here's like a heavy ass huge box huge
that you can open and you don't know
where it came from yes and it says
zionist so i know it's a cloud mattress
i don't even know what size of mattress
it is okay i gotta open it up and she
posts on twitter and nick huber sweaty
startup says that was from me uh
and and i go oh very funny and he goes
no that was seriously for me i uh we
wanted you to know i invested into his
storage business and he said we wanted
you to be able to sleep well at night
knowing that your money is uh
uh like being taken care of and i was
like
well i appreciate the sincerity that's
lovely yeah who the hell has a like i
don't have like a spare an unmattressed
bed yeah like i don't have an
unmattressed bed like what were you
thinking like maybe a blender would have
been cool or like just chocolate like
like like a pillow a pillow
yeah like a fancy pillow i could use
another one of those he gave me an extra
mattress and so we've been texting our
friends like does anyone need a mattress
he created a pain in the ass for you yes
i'm like dude just send me chocolate
covered nuts
like
give me like like some flavored like
some weird fruit or something i don't
want a [__] mattress he sent me a
mattress i've got this huge mattress in
the front door problem and i've got
guests coming on friday and i'm like
looking like a redneck with this
mattress
we have a bed they're staying in the bed
that's already in the guest room and i'm
like i look like an idiot i look like a
country bumpkin with just a mattress on
my front door and i'm like oh just
ignore that we'll get rid of it so uh
i'm on board with better gifting nick
huber i this will make it to you
i i really appreciate the the gesture
though it was very nice um but like
maybe like peanut butter cups and like
chocolate covered nuts and like some
chocolate turtles would be more
sufficient
i love it
all right so that's one quick idea the
factory gift idea with the outbound
outreach to every fba and amazon seller
and
shopify seller and i think you could i
think you could side hustle your way
into a million dollars a year doing that
okay here's another uh random thing have
you uh have you ever seen
uh emf protected pants
is that for your computer on your balls
is that your phone yeah uh no emf this
might be em something else
electromagnetic whatever
radiation i'm on board with this though
i hate
like i i don't know it's emf the studies
i don't know exactly what it is but like
basically having your laptop on your lap
and that heat is not i don't know if
it's radiation or what it is it like has
proven to kill your sperm another thing
like wearing whitey tighties you know
like tight underwear where your balls
are against your body that actually uh
kills your sperm because it it heats
your body up too much let the baby swing
you know yeah you can't be you can't be
the birds gotta fly yes
you can keep them in the nest
so
um
so i've i've noticed that there's a few
people in my life who i they're like the
canary and the coal mine like they they
kind of get really into stuff
and i'm when they first say i'm like why
are you even thinking about this why do
you even care about this um
you're you're one of these people by the
way where it's like dude sam just got
really into [__] mobility
and like you know stretching he's like
got really serious about like
ripped dudes who want to sw stretch and
be like super mobile or it'll be like
you know
um
he's on this kick about like really
wanting like uh toughness challenges
like life is too good he's too soft so
he's craving this like ch
core primal challenge in his life uh is
that just sam being sam actually what it
ends up being is like sam being ahead of
the curve by like three years and it's
gonna become it's gonna be proven to be
like quite popular um
there's a few people in my life that are
like that my brother-in-law's like this
you're like this my trainer i've learned
is one of these people where
he'll say something and he's like you
know super into this thing i'm like i've
never like he'll be like oh yeah dude i
take kratom it's like oh kratom like
what the [__] is kratom like do you know
what kratom is no it's like basically so
so he's big into like these like kind of
supplements nootropics which like
you know
if the promise of them is amazing but
you like can't tell if they work or not
like people who believe in them are like
oh this feels great but it's it's that
thing we talked about before it's like
the best product in the world is cbd for
dogs because yeah
you think you're giving them you know
pain relief but you'll never know if it
does anything and like cbd for humans is
like that too but the dogs can't talk
and um
and so there's a whole bunch of these
like kind of nootropics or supplements
that's like oh yeah i take lion's mane
and i take like you know [__] milk of
magnesia i don't know whatever just a
bunch of random ass names and then later
like he said he was telling me about
like tangaly and then dr hubermann came
on he's like yeah i don't do
testosterone anymore i do like i get it
from these other uh like more natural
herbs like tangali and whatever i was
like dude there's only two people in my
life that i've ever said this name tanga
ali and like it's these two people and
so i've just noticed he's ahead of the
curve on a lot of these whether it's
like fashion fitness
supplements nootropics
you know like books that he's into
and so on the supplement side he's like
really this thing called kratom uh which
is kind of like a advil um like you
don't take instead of you taking a set
of advil so it's like kind of like
it helps with your aches and pains
without the side effects of like like
thin your blood or hurt your kidneys
yeah like you're bad for your liver and
[__] like that yeah
and um
so anyways
where i'm going with this okay so he's
like oh yeah dude he's got his fashion
line coming out where he's like making
clothes basically just like i'm his only
customer right now because it's like not
released but i just get to have a bunch
of his [__] and i'm like oh this is
amazing um he's like yeah the shorts on
these the pockets have like emf
protection and i was like what
he's like oh yeah like i'm big into like
you know just why not why not have emf
protection
and i was like from what like he's like
yeah your phone's in your pocket all day
right next to your balls like you just
don't want that you know i want to have
kids i i don't want to be having all
this stuff there and i'm like i guess
you're right i guess i'm pretty sick i
was like it's so normal that everybody
puts in their pocket so like
is there something to be worried about
and i call this footwear fudd which
stands for fear uncertainty and doubt so
i i just made that up
yeah there's a general trend i've
created here called footwear and i think
that footwear is going to be anything
that's like oh yeah you know like blue
blocker like uh light glasses um emf
radiation proof pants um
you know it's like uh
you know like and that's that's not to
say that they're all like it's not to
say that any of this is false like it
might be totally true but it's basically
preying on people that are when you tell
them oh did you know that paraben you
should never have aluminum in your
deodorant and they're like what aluminum
am i going to die all right i'm never
using old spice i'll use native
deodorant instead it's like paraben free
it's like what the [__] a paraben but
i i guess i've heard parabens are bad
for you you know um like
the guy who came on the show he was like
oh yeah i don't drink out of plastic
because you know phthalates i don't
drink out of plastic either and it's
like but yeah it's still super common
but the smart people i know are like
starting to say this word phthalate i
never heard this word before but i'm
starting to hear this and it tells me
there's a bunch of people that as they
become aware they're going to start to
steer away
or teflon pans
right exactly like the non-stick or
whatever yeah so i think there's just a
whole class of products that are just
footwear and you can just find the next
flood of like what are people afraid of
it's like oh like they want to do like
um uv cleaning of their phone and their
toys because uv kills uh you know covet
and you know uv red lights that's a
great one footwear that's fantastic so a
few more like the water filters so
there's those charcoal
silver water filters that are everywhere
i think just justin mayer said he tried
to get a built like a huge one so all of
his home water goes through with this
thing
yeah said he has like intense i asked
him i go what do you have what do you do
for water he goes i go way over but i
have like a 12 foot tall system that's
filtering is it like is it called like
it's called
berkeley or berkeley what it's called
but when rob dear dick was on he said
that too he's like i'm making a shower
head filter company because like oh yeah
what if i found out that i'm showering
in [__] toxic chemicals well then i'm
gonna buy this attachment that purifies
it like
if you just put a little seed of doubt
into my brain
i'm going to be like yeah why not i'm
just going to add on the side of safety
and on in the same realm with that and i
actually i would want to look into this
but i think laptops on men lapse is like
a massive
issue right i i like it could
potentially be quite you could just make
a whole company just protecting men's
balls
from like the modern day you know
harm
it's like yeah here's a laptop tray
that's like [__] made out of
kryptonite i was like you can't pass
through this here's your shorts put your
pi put it in this pocket it won't won't
fry your balls uh you know wear this
underwear uh because you know your
underwear has you know
cotton phosphors it's like what's a
cotton phosphor i don't know sean just
made it up but it's bad for your balls
and so it's like did you just make that
up it's good
it sounded good right dude i'm telling
you the heat it does freak me out like
having that he like i feel it and i'm
like oh this is horrible for me so i i
have like a pad like i you put a pad on
my lap
you know pomade you need to apply to
your balls every night uh before you
sleep because you know that when you
sleep gravity pulls your balls and it's
bad for you like how do you like make up
an endless number of bulbs okay here's
this one that i saw these guys launch
and they advertised with us early on and
i was like this is the stupidest thing
i've ever heard of why are you guys even
doing this and now it's a billion dollar
company manscaped
have you heard about manscaped i have i
asked a buddy i said what's one of the
best investments in your portfolio what
are your best investments i thought he's
named some tech company some cyber
security company he goes oh manscape is
great because they raised like only a
tiny amount of money and they're worth
like yeah like close to a billion
dollars is it a billion dollar company
you think i i don't know something like
that but they sponsor the ufc and that's
a really expensive sponsorship and they
sponsor a ton of stuff if you told me
that they do like 150 million in revenue
i wouldn't be surprised i think it's
definitely over 100 million in revenue
for you think it's over 200
i mean i don't know and i've i've never
used one i told her i told sarah to buy
one for me because i won one for my nose
hair and i think they have like why did
sarah have to buy for you why didn't you
just buy it she wanted a christmas
present for i told my christmas i was
like give me like the nose hair one um i
think they have a nose hair one uh but
uh
like
one is it all in one i don't mind using
i will give you that cover they give you
that air cover to be like yeah i just
want to trim my beard in my nose and uh
oh what do you know it comes in all your
attachments maybe your boy will start
manscaping yeah i'm cool with chair like
using that on my face and i'm no the the
nose one's different uh but
but the the manscape like buzzer
it it's just a normal i think it's just
a normal buzzer i i don't know how it's
actually different than like a normal
hair much different and they crushed it
this cat i never in a million years
would have thought that this was gonna
work it sounded like a joke when it came
out i remember just being like oh that's
a funny that's a funny joke of a company
cool cool joke of the day for a startup
yes and they kill it they sponsor all
the major like boxing and ufc stuff
these guys are killing it uh
and it doesn't look so
i'm on board with with with the
protector balls that's a good business
and fud is a phenomenal uh name what's
it stand for footwear uh fud is fear
uncertainty and doubt so they say this
in the market a lot like if people are
like oh i heard china's gonna ban
bitcoin or like
isn't it true that like uh you know
satoshi was a you know part of the nsa
it's like this is just fud you're
spreading to get people to be uncertain
and doubt and sell their positions dude
that's great like compression socks i
buy compression saw so that's fud wear i
have no idea if it works but it's what
is it supposed to do
compression socks when you run i have
calf pain and achilles pain all the time
compression socks or socks that you pull
really high up to your knees and they
have a lot of compression on it and it
keeps your calf calves tight so if you
wear like compression shorts like that
tight underwear for your thighs it's
like that for your calves and ankles
gotcha okay i like it i dig it um
can we wrap up with one thing uh
so recently this bitcoin thing um
craig wright i don't know much about it
other than like one article i read i
guess he's an australian guy and he was
being sued by this person who wanted a
share of the money for
what's the story
uh i don't know about his lawsuit but i
know about craig wright and that he
basically for a long time has been
claiming to be
uh satoshi nakamoto so well so he claims
to be the creator of bitcoin and then
people who are smart in the community
are like there's no [__] way so
people but this lawsuit basically he's
being sued by the spouse of someone
that's me this craig wright had a
partner the partner died and the spouse
of the partner sued craig wright and
craig wright won the lawsuit and winning
for what uh she said that you owe me
money because of this reason and that
reason we created this you and my
husband created this thing together you
owe us some money and in winning i
forget exactly how it worked but in
winning the case the
jurors said well no you're satoshi and
you worked on this alone
and so uh
like in order for him to win in a weird
i don't know the exact details but in
order for him to win they were basically
saying yes we believe you're satoshi and
satoshi worked alone
so okay here's the here's the story so
uh kleinman versus wright uh the jury
ruled that david kleiner's relationship
to correct did not constitute a business
partnership meaning the estate was not
entitled to a share of the satoshi
nakamoto fortune which wright claims to
have control over as the self-reported
creator of bitcoin the
jury ruled against wright on the
conversion count awarding
awarding 100 million dollars to kleinman
what
a rule against right yeah so he said
they got 100 million out of it i don't
know because i thought he was
celebrating it was a little confusing
but the point was is that this like
this legal team okay they wanted
billions they didn't get that but they
got a hundred million against him for
the unauthorized use of funds from
climate rights shared venture wnk info
defense research llc
i don't know this is from something else
so did is this guy the guy who started
it that's what i wanted so basically um
so he claims to have invented bitcoin
then um there's a great clip by the way
of vitalik buterin the creator of
ethereum uh co-creator of ethereum
uh on stage and he goes uh there's they
were talking about it and usually people
like you know like
in a w in a conference panel people are
usually pretty like
you know they don't take shots at people
like live there and he just he just
pipes because you want to know what i
think
and they're like yes we'd love to know
what you think he goes
he goes um
he gives this like quick like two-minute
rant that just destroys craig right
where he's like i think if you're the
creator of bitcoin you ever and
everybody was saying you're not and you
keep trying to tell people you are all
you have to do is one simple thing you
just have to sign something with with
satoshi's wallet and that will just show
that you're him and the fact that you're
not doing that like the you know he he
calls them like some like you know
awesome razer ox razor or whatever like
just some term like that he's like the
simplest explanation here is that you're
not satoshi because if you have a simple
way to prove your claim and you do not
prove your claim using the simple way
you cannot prove your claim
and um so you kind of just like [__] on
them right there so who crowd went wild
so who is this you think is he he's he
just died or he's still quiet
um
the best theory is that it's uh
that it's this guy hal i forgot his name
is hal uh alfini um
this was so hal finney was like a
cryptographer he received the first
bitcoin transaction he was the like the
second wallet and normally like
what does the developer do when they
test something that's like oh i sent it
from like sean a to sean b like my test
account basically like that's how i do
the first transaction
and um
he was like very active in the forums
and then he died right around the time
he got als and died around the time that
the last known time that satoshi ever
posted anything um so you know what he
was like why wouldn't he tell
do you think he
why wouldn't he like tell his wife or
his family or you know like
because it looks like he has a wife on
these pictures yeah
well a maybe he did and b um like you
know some people are
so mission driven in their thing and
their thinking and like you know there
was a there's a real genius of
the idea of being like i'm gonna have
this as a pseudonymous name satoshi
nakamoto i'm not gonna use my real name
which means i'll never get the credit
for being a genius if this works
but also it like it's kind of like the
parent dies so the child can survive
it's like the only way a currency like
this could have really worked is if you
couldn't point to the creator because
then they would just attack the creator
they would say the creator has too much
they'd say this guy has a ulterior
motives he has control he's he's too
powerful to you know he's just the new
the new bad guy you know okay you're bad
at the federal reserve and the
governments uh yeah now you're mad at
this guy for for private citizen being
in control of this so do you think this
is him
i personally think it's him um like i've
looked into a couple times about like
who are the most likely candidates um
you know is it a group of people uh was
it the government themselves was it one
person and it does seem like it was uh
like you know i guess like i shouldn't
say it does seem like it there's really
no evidence of the existing evidence
that's there this kind of like
speculative data point you have how
phineas fits the story in my world view
the best so i think it's him god that's
i love these mysteries
which would mean that it's it's sort of
gone like his coins are locked up um
unless he gave him to his wife unless he
gave her the keys uh and like you know
and she and told her don't touch it
because it hasn't moved not a single
coin has moved uh ever and um you know i
think if he did it let's say he did give
her instructions how would i give
instructions i would say
um
i would probably not actually let her
have it i would say
this file is going to be available to
you on this date
um 20 years from now
and i would say you know follow the
instructions inside so i wouldn't even
give her the opportunity to make a bad
decision
because i would say if these move before
bitcoin wins
um then it'll be this will be just very
destructive for it like if the creator
of bitcoin starts to sell bitcoin
that will trigger like a huge sell-off
in the market because it'll be like oh
the creator's alive they don't believe
they're selling their coins who is it
it'll create this like whole drama it'll
hurt the project but has any money ever
left his account no
not a single satoshi has ever left his
account so then he would have had to
have create a different account for her
to live on or something yeah which could
have easily happened right um
you know at some point but you know
people can also see the ledger so they
know who all satoshi sent the they know
which wallet satoshi sent coins to
and um some of them are like known
identities like the other people that
were in this like crypto like the
cypherpunk community that wanted to test
out the project early on uh but like you
know he very easily could have just had
her set up mining a mining rig so it
didn't even have to come from his
account he could just say because he
didn't give himself the coins he mined
the coins sure it's just that mining was
so easy at that time so
you know she could be minor number eight
um you know that mind some coins and
that's it that's she can live off that
yeah god well we should see like you
know house finney how's she living is
she like in a in a 40 million dollar
home in venice i i don't even know if he
i i mean there's a woman with all these
pictures with him like it looks like a
wife i don't even know anything about
her i just
googled it it doesn't say anything about
the wikipedia about his wife um
but oh yeah his wife raised yeah so he
does have a wife
yeah i'd be curious i'm looking at
pictures of his house when he's dying
like pictures of him dying and he's in
his home it does not look fancy
yeah
yeah also als just looks so brutal man
yeah it feels like the worst completely
debilitated
uh that's really tough
yeah so anyway that's fascinating we
should do like an entire episode on that
that's this [__] is so interesting to me
yeah i agree we should we should just do
the research of like okay what is all
the research that's out there and like
what's the conclusion i think people are
i'm fascinated by like this story i
think it's one of the coolest [__]
out of straight out of a movie but it's
actually real life things that has ever
happened you know i like that and silk
road but i think the silk road case is
far more cut and dry than anyone thinks
i think ross did it i think ross did
everything
right
you know what i mean what's the con
what's the controversy people think what
many people were running it dred scott
pirate whatever the the what's the name
dread pirates roberts or whatever
uh they're saying that that was multiple
people and whenever i post about raw
soul bright
people are like free ross and i'm like
well like
he did kind of hire people to kill one
of like other people like i don't know
like what you have you seen the comments
so you have a youtube video about your
story yeah they hate and they're they're
like they're like like
there's like an army of people that love
ross and hate they hate anybody that
says anything bad you didn't even say
anything bad i didn't say anything bad i
said i think he did it but like but like
my thing is like uh like i mean he sold
like he sold drugs so there's some
consequence to that not life but some
consequence but if you did like murder
for hire
yeah
life is is definitely fair if you do it
three times totally fair right and when
like i read that book american kingpin i
looked at some of the evidence that i'm
like yeah there were some bad cops
working on the case and those guys got
in trouble but
it definitely seems like this guy did it
i don't understand how there's any
shadow of a doubt right
by the way fran finney's twitter bio
i'll just leave it on this note she she
says i graduated from caltech i spent 35
amazing years married to hal finney um
who lived with als in 2009 2014.
currently living in dubai i vow to spend
the rest of my life making him proud
i thought that was nice
yeah man she seems like a sweetheart and
she turns out
turns out nothing happens to me drives
like a ferrari and a bugatti and like
only wears gucci
badass for the rest of my life with
these fresh ass gucci's yeah gucci
lights
hilarious you see this uh did you ever
see that meme you know that guy
husballah the little like the little i
love him so he tweeted out this thing he
goes man people say i had this like
people always talk about my disability
do you see this meme yes and what did he
say he goes yeah i got disability to
make that bread
make sure him holding a huge block of
cash he's like disability to make this
money i love that kid he's not a kid i
think he's like 20. yeah i don't know
what to say i'm gonna get canceled just
trying to like
just try to
describe anything about him without
being offensive so i'm just not gonna
say anything all right let's roll i'm
out of here
[Music]
you